hello everybody my name
is markiplier
and
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and for those who don't know that means
i am a youtube personality over the
years i have had the privilege to work
with some awesome youtubers and play
some awesome games i do both of these
things that's actually pretty good um
welcome to
what used to be talk to transformer but
is now in fact in for kit which i think
stands for infernal kit because they
summon the powers of hell to be able to
uh create these random words if you
didn't know uh we played around with
this over on unison is way back when you
can't find it now don't worry it's gone
and also we played around with this back
when it was talk to transformer that was
back then but on distractible we played
around with infrakit and i was like i
kind of want to play around with it
again to see what it can do so that's
why i'm here i don't really have a goal
this is pretty open-ended i'm just gonna
see what it can do and uh maybe i'll
embarrass myself and i stood
upon the pressed piece of the cliff
contemplating
all the
terrible decisions
that had led me
to this very moment
or was it audrey
[Music]
hey the thunderous downpour and followed
the incessant cry of the tree frogs
stopping to see if i could hear anything
else i saw a very large shadow fly over
my head and as i turned to see who or
what it was i found myself lying on a
piece of carpet holding a hairbrush in
my hand i looked around and realized i
was in some type of large room filled
with what seemed to be over a hundred
women and possibly one or two men
i searched the crowd and noticed that
there well it didn't seem like it
stopped at the end there's a few
settings here that i'm not 100 sure of
obviously length generator let's keep
that like suit 360. uh you can add
keywords interesting you can select the
category pause at the end is what i had
selected because i thought that it would
end where it thinks it should and
apparently that's where it thinks it
should nucleus sampling top peepee value
closer will produce less variety more
repetition is that
well who would want what's probable
controls the randomness of sampling the
creativity okay the creativity everybody
the the creativity uh values greater
than one will increase the chance
i'm not gonna worry about that
let's try that again my hand was
trembling
the gun rattling in my grip
in front of me stood
ronald mcdonald
i knew what i had to do
i brought my other hand up i let it
slowly open
okay uh
it it went a little racist okay so ai is
an interesting thing if you remember
when uh microsoft had their ai control
their twitter for a bit or maybe they
created an account for it um it sampled
what was already on twitter and then
became horrifyingly racist
and uh just started tweeting absolutely
inane insane
horrifying things turns out that ai
in any case could do that and that
happens so let's try that again i was so
happy filled with
sunshine and rainbows all was good in
the world and i felt
the glorious feeling of love and
harmony
bursting in my
soul what a wonderful place this world
was that is until my four-year-old
daughter walked into the room and said
dad look at those mushrooms i told her
that mushrooms don't grow on the earth
they're made of the devil she said i
don't know mom
i don't know mom they're really big they
look like they could be i explained to
her again that the mushrooms are made of
the
what i'm gonna increase it to 420 water
the mud water the mushrooms made of what
are they made of obviously the book is
indeed being used to lure children into
the dark world of deceit deception and
witchcraft that is quite a jump from
their goal of improving children's
education
oh god i don't know how to pronounce
those lexian put those into a
text-to-speech and play what those
pronunciations are referral chimutera
and set c moyo had previously contested
the allegations of misappropriation of
the funds by claiming that in fact they
were trying to build a school where boys
and girls will learn together
i don't know i don't know knock knock
who's there knock knock who's there
auntie doris aunty doris who auntie
doris the evil witch who took your soul
auntie doris who's been dead for 600
years and can now walk the earth auntie
doris who takes on the form of a man
uncle herb entered the room carrying a
purple robe uncle herb i just bought
this as good will auntie doris who
[Laughter]
hunted doris the evil witch who took
your soul auntie doris who's my dad
oh my god for some reason this literally
only works properly with uh knock knock
jokes um i'm hoping that lexian played
in the beginning of this episode uh the
knock knock joke that really knocked us
on our ass
oh my god knock knock who's there keep
out you are not wanted here knock knock
who's there [ __ ] you stay out let me in
who's there step aside i'm married who's
there leave me alone i'm getting horny
who's there don't touch me if you touch
me i'll have to sue you knock knock
who's there santa claus you've been very
good this year
you can listen to that episode in the
description below um let me try that
again knock knock who's there taco bell
taco bell who taco bell who taco bell
who taco bell it's me taco bell patriots
lineman brian schwanke is a machine and
he's even been spotted sleeping in a
cafeteria with a backpack full of
good
okay
knock knock who's there pizza pizza
pizza who pizza with apples ooh pizza
with apples pizza pizza with apples why
do you have a pizza with apples sue
makes me so makes me give pizza with
apples sue smile don't give up smile
don't give up smile don't give up what
do you have that's red mushrooms
mushrooms
all right well let's try funny joke
funny joke
funny joke doc dr glitz what no stop
pushing the funny joke
stop stop stop stop
i said funny joke funny joke peyton
still hasn't told his boss he's on
maternity leave i finally made the
mistake of asking him about it yesterday
and i swear his response was i just
don't feel right telling him what he's
afraid he's gonna get fired anyway he
was convinced that he'd keep a secret
from now from just about everyone else
but i'm a little worried i hope this
isn't a mistake today i've
hilarious joke guys guys
guys i've got the most hilarious and
funny
joke to tell you
oh boy you're gonna laugh
[Laughter]
i've just been sitting here rehearsing
it in my notebook and it's starting to
get to the point where it might just
come out right i'm just going to tell
you how i write jokes so i'm going to
write down a couple of things the punch
line then a few things after that then i
say it i say it and then i say it
god uh
look out behind you scared a deer you'll
certainly that deer are pretty spooked
by vehicles i've even been known to run
over one or two on purpose when i wasn't
paying attention was caught out after
dark that's when i turned my engine off
and the windows down the music up and
put on my safety into the hands of the
man i know i know it's not legal at
least i'm not breaking the law
mostly
what
poopy what
big old
butt
but
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh you know what i guess that's to be
expected i don't know i was surprised so
this is it
i'm dying
seems unfair my blood's
spilling
out
out from
the gash in my side
oh what a world
if only i hadn't
lived
a life full of so many
regrets
the only good thing to come from the
slaughter are the dramatic screams of
the mourners who cling to me every
single one of them they're trying to
break me away from the great machine in
my mind but they can't break the pawns
that i have made me what i am i can hear
a woman scream it's not fair but it
doesn't have an effect on me at all i
wish she would shut up the clock says
midnight and i am just
and i am just a cold body with the clock
ticking away the blood trickling from my
stomach and up through the hole in my
neck it's all right just breathe about
the other my name's jen i'm a very
special being i'm a prisoner of the
system and i have many deaths to pay my
work goes on no matter what i become
this is my legacy you're my very first
convert to your lovely service tyler i'm
a man in the final one
okay um
wade and bob decided to take a trip
out into the woods that's when things
got weird
they found what looked like a cave but
when they entered it it was nothing like
it seemed instead of a cave there was a
red door and on the outside of the door
was a mossy inscription it read once you
have entered the force you will never be
the same this is not the woods that you
are used to this is not your childhood
or your parent's childhood this is not
even the kind of force you saw on
television tyler and mark started a
podcast called go my favorite sports
team
tyler came to visit we went out to eat
lots of fun at least for tyler and me
what did anyone else do get ready for
the impact coming at you from a young
woman who has been married for two
months and doesn't need any more sleep
my thought processes are like i think
most 18 year old thoughts are in the
here and now
not in a few years i will feel this way
i am free from all responsibility
i've done it
i've solved world hunger
here's the plan here's
the plan 10 million pounds of chicken 10
million chicken breasts 10 million drums
610 million wings wait what how would i
go about gathering 10 million pounds of
chicken meat first question is where
would i find it next how would i get it
for those of you wondering what happened
to the half my grandma cooking chicken
whole chicken boneless done skinless
thingy i know you are
what uh let me go to a different
category let me just go pure fiction it
was dark i was scared it was dark it was
weird it wasn't dark when the plane
dropped i was scared though the plane
went up in the air i was happy i was
happy too it was dark when i opened my
eyes it was dark and i opened my eyes it
wasn't dark but i opened my eyes but i
had my eyes open so it wasn't dark but
it was dark i went to bed but the lights
came on so it was dark it was dark and i
went to bed it was dark i went to bed
don't don't know don't know i need you
we're almost there i can't not for you
not for me this is killing me philip
[Music]
they made love with quick angry thrusts
but then it was over
what i don't know what to do robin who's
robin all right fiction's a bust let's
do a news story um there's also another
setting here to
start at the beginning yeah okay uh
florida man caught dead with 17 rain
deer
uh bolted to giant sleigh
and a seven-year-old girl charged with
grand theft authorities in coleur county
said daniel goolsby was arrested and
charged with animal cruelty and grand
theft after police found ghouls be in
his backyard dead in a pickup truck with
a hat full of reindeer in the bed
according to nbc 2 goolsby and his
daughter had been on the run since
christmas night the station said the
items had stolen from home i have an
idea there's a uh subreddit called
offbeat which has like weird news titles
i'm just gonna plug a few into these and
see where it goes six percent of
americans think they could beat a
grizzly bear in hand-to-hand combat
that's a scary thought however americans
are not going to be helping by adding
guns to bear proof bear cages
conservative official warrants hunters
in wyoming and idaho where grizzlies
live
i started attaching rifles hunting
knives night vision goggles and other
gear to bear proof crates the purpose of
the nets which are designed to keep
bears in place while hunters shoot them
is to reduce the what is there there's
the number of grizzlies killed by hunter
city officials of the u.s fish and
wildlife service at issue is grizzly
hunting which has been banned in the
lower 48 states for more than 40 years
but the hunts are still legal in montana
and wyoming the bans have to do with the
animals and danger status and strict
protection
all right
fascinating asteroid the size of 350
giraffes to fly past earth this week
what
what
oh god i think this is just actually
news let me
let me start this over again here's
where to watch an asteroid the size of a
giraffe and the fifth largest ever
discovered will fly past earth on friday
prompting nasa to launch its preliminary
defense telescopes to monitor the space
rock and offer them last minute safety
tips for observers the flyby the
asteroid in 2018 la is an opportunity
for scientists to test a worldwide
asteroid detection tracking network
all right here we go semi-trailer crash
outside pittsburgh dumps more than seven
tons of hot dog filler on
what is hot dog filler
oh god no
oh god no they just
oh they just they drive that into just a
goddamn truck i'm still gonna eat hot
dogs i guess but let's see what uh
infrakit thinks of it a semi-trailer
crash on the i-279 in pennsylvania
dumping hot dog meat onto the road the
truck stuck concrete median this is just
the exact thing that actually happened
give me some nonsense ability here
137 [ __ ] worlds fauxhawks falling
against my period damn she's
ah
go no
that's not right that's uh that's a
little too the sampling temperature is a
little too spicy there let's try uh 125.
a flatbed trailer carrying more than
seven tons of controversial hotdog
filler crashed early friday outside
pittsburgh spilling onto the highway and
leaving a mess for cleanup crews and
police the crash took place at 4 48 am
in franken's frankstown township trying
one more time let's get a little more
random here let's go 150.
freeway on
half very against me several dangers
when blowing a roth client's fair
biggest risk
oh god stop stop stop
bringing it
reset that i did it i killed it
after all that time i finally managed to
hunt that monster down there was a
special event where food place was at
from 24 to 26 daylight the only two
non-vampires in the three-part event
here are my thoughts and observations
after clearing it
oh it's a walk through oh okay
uh elden ring
el din ring roads get
traveling to elton doesn't have to be a
difficult journey
oh my god it's really starting to lose
it here we go uh i've got a website
called 101 funny clean jokes that'll
make you laugh your pants off what do
dentists call their x-rays depends on
your school dentists have long believed
that the dental record is the only
clinically important record in dentistry
for researchers
all right hilarious what did one ocean
say to the other ocean what is there in
the shape of an island that can't give
forth plath of delight till the sound of
the wind and waves of whispering love
and serenity and peace what has land
ever said to sky what is sand ever said
to see
island and sea are lovers and the hours
in love are the hours spent without a
thought of sleep let the sea murmur her
sadness and be gone let the ocean lift
her voice god that
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this just
a [ __ ] up coincidence do we even know
why this goes again completely against
what we learned in kindergarten to not
look up to people but maybe it's because
i don't give a [ __ ] about you i will see
you and i will laugh share this article
now one more story from japan read these
stories first japanese person to get
naked on the u.s
wow uh all right knock knock
who's there snow white snow white who
snow white who snow white who will this
guy do the imposter cackled as he stared
back at this shifty and terrified
vampire and nodded his head up and down
once
[ __ ] you well it's not very funny
[ __ ] and balls when did you become so
[ __ ] insulting
in fact [ __ ] you two you know oh god i
don't know bet you can't make me laugh
two boys are best friends one day the
friend wants to sell some gold bouillon
and the boy hesitates you don't
understand gold sells for big bucks and
i don't have enough money to buy the
bouillon the friend's father says that's
true my boy but i don't think he can
make me laugh i don't think he can make
me laugh so the boy continues to sit on
his knees and wait for the laugh
okay
i got this new anime plot basically
there's this high school girl except
she's got huge moves i mean some serious
hunkers a real sense of badonkers
packing some
doughbong hankeros i wonder what it's
going to do with this
[Music]
bygone cougars stuff she has such huge
boobs and she's so huge and her boobs
are so huge and the other girl's boobs
are so huge they look like big shrimp
lobsters being held at 12 year old girl
hulking
she's such a slab then they start doing
she gets pregnant from having sex with
an actual piece of fishing line so big
all right she's got huge boobs i mean
some serious honkers a real set of
badonkas packing some doban hankeros
cougars what happens next
transfer student shows up with even
bigger bonk hanukkah hoogs humongous
uncle hung
eek how did you lose an over 17 year old
in your dorm
i suppose just don't tell her the
library is
you fail me humongous
[Music]
please sir i think i'm not fit to be
your girlfriend you know all the teenage
pregnancy and everything i'll punch you
in the face if you keep asking what are
you asking again they look at each other
what the [ __ ] did you say about me you
little [ __ ]
you think you can get away with saying
that [ __ ] to me over the internet think
again [ __ ] as we speak i am contacting
my secret network of spies across the
usa and your ip is being traced right
now so you better prepare for this storm
that storm that wipes out the pathetic
little thing you call your life
that's word for word i could be anywhere
eddie
over seven different places oh man the
actual the original is 700 ways but
seven different ways
wow
uh i don't know if i can do any better
than that big bouncing bong
hongo
maybe i need a refresh knock knock
who's there falco falco who falco who
falco yo this is your boy falco i'm
gonna bring my team and we're gonna go
to the tournament all right let's go see
i wasn't all that good the guy at the
store uh oh
this is so
incredibly boring
i can't see anything it's so quiet in
here it's painful [ __ ] the guys must be
having a heart attack in the corner he
isn't moving at all it's the oddest
thing i've ever seen
all right i have no idea what else i can
put into this on the last day of the
year 12 monkeys entered the store and
only one left alive on the first day of
the year three monkeys entered the store
and only one went left alive on the
second day of the year six monkeys
entered the store and only one left
alive on the third day of the year nine
monkeys entered the store and only one
left alive on the fourth day of the year
fourteen monkeys out of the store and
only one left alive on the fifth day of
the year
sixteen monkeys entered the store and
only one left alive on the sixteenth
because apparently uh that's all in for
kid is which is debunking
a bunch of monkeys slamming on a
keyboard so thank you everybody so much
for watching my vlogs i hope you all
enjoy the gifts that i made for you
after i make a video you are allowed to
ask me a question in a poll on the board
please choose from these question do you
like it answer will you be a witness you
please write your answer in the comments
do you like it
will you be a witness you really are so
pretty why is your hair like that those
are the only valid comments that you can
make in the comments below and if anyone
has made any other comments that are not
pertaining to these specific answers for
comments please downvote those comments
so that only the relevant comments can
stay up and remember you have your three
options here if you like the video be
sure to
share it also if you want to visit and
see how much fun we have while she is in
the hospital
anyway and as always i will see you
on the other side
bye bye
[Music]
you